the waves are crashing but there's no
ocean here
the best surfers in the world are
training for the next championships and
it's not hawaii they've come to
here in the mountains of northern spain
the waves are automatic
the boss shows how it's done the wave
breaks evenly it's ideal for surfing
years of experimentation were worth it
we go through crises every year
just when we think the wave is perfect
something goes wrong
it's usually a mechanical fault
the problem is that we have to drain off
all the water
in the meantime the cost of the project
is manageable the developers say the
electricity bill works out at about 22
cents a wave
although this is a test site the
technology is already on sale
is this the surfing mecca of the future
the atlantic is only 10 minutes away
good waves here is a question of
patience and strength
you can't calculate nature
or can you
this control pad is decisive when it
comes to making waves to order
karine frisch and her spanish husband
test the setup in the morning
the couple's seven-year-old son is the
first out on his board
when he was born his parents had just
started studying wave dynamics and how
they behave in a pool setting like this
how the technology works is a trade
secret it cost millions of euros to
build the site
some funding came from the basque
regional government some other investors
are here today
europe's largest surfboard maker has
sent a few surfers to test the setup and
they're thrilled
i tried it this morning and it was a
great experience the wave had a
continuous velocity
a lot faster than normal waves
in the sea the waves are irregular
but this one is so perfect that you have
a chance to surf in a much more intense
way throughout the wave
all they'll say is that there's a trench
running under the central walkway with a
kind of plow on rails
the wave forces the surfer away from any
potential danger
the german architect is partly
responsible for details like that
he designed the floor of the pool
the shape of the plow which forms the
wave is also being studied so every wave
is examined
the australians are there already gary
ross wants to build five across the
country
they'll cost around 10 million euros
each
the investor is a passionate surfer
himself
so can the wave park replace nature
this is not intended to replace
ocean-based waste but for all those
people who wanted to get into surfing
there's a lot of disincentives around
surfing in the ocean
you have to worry about the conditions
you can only do it during the daytime
you can only do it on the coast
whereas here
all of those disincentives are removed
so um if it's absolutely pumping on the
coast sure i'll be out there surfing
ocean waves but for my four-year-old son
and for my two and a half year old
daughter you know this is where they're
going to learn to serve
karine frisch and her husband are
convinced there's a market for their
product
they see the wave garden as forming the
core of wider tourist developments
association of uh
soul cities on the wall mm-hmm all
course is one of the services is another
santa cruz in california order and all
of them see how they can get more from
from the tourists from surfing
saturday's attraction
it's very smooth
there's more of a pipe
and nothing to get into your way
there are plenty of rival concepts for
artificial waves but they only exist as
computer simulations
the real thing only exists in the basque
country
you